[Music]
man those perseves
were absolutely amazing but super simple
now according to kiko
they're not simple to get these arranged
for me to meet a very talented
local sea barnacle harvester who'll show
me how to really get these prize assets
ricardo hi bud
it's amazing today good to see you bud i
was happy to be here
ricardo cosme is that pester best
harvester that does not look
easy the forages year round for the
barnacles and knows the waters here
like the back of his hand look at those
waves gonna be rough
the harder the waves are yes and the
deeper
the crosshairs are right the bigger they
are and the better one
specifically we got perce
yep
this is size important for you or
thickness
no we're talking about the procedure we
are talking about purple guys
of course you need thickness of the size
both bars two centimeters and like
thickness of a finger gotcha those are
the ones perfect gotcha
they will cost roughly 90 100 euros
kilogram
a hundred euros a kilo yeah because
you're risking your life doing this
yeah i have to check on my shorts
are even harder to gather than to
pronounce each year in portugal
a handful of people die collecting them
hopefully
the ocean isn't hungry for a new victim
we need to be constantly watching never
turn your back to the ocean no
never no no no gotcha captain
man like spiderman seriously can you
slow down
now all the sudden you start to see the
size of those waves you don't see them
yet
you will feel them time to get wet
ready
for a veteran like ricardo this is a
walk in the park
but it makes me wish i had a stunt
double yourself
finding the right size barnacles takes
incredible timing
great strength and just a touch of crazy
this is not like foraging berries ah
this is foraging on steroids
ah wow that is amazing
bloody how aren't they beautiful
uh really beautiful wow now it's your
turn
but first we need to wait there it's
coming a massive set it's already
look at the line let's
[Music]
be careful
for me
i can't guys let's search another hole
with the final cooking a few days time
failure is not an option so
ricardo suggests we try our luck in a
different spot
try to catch those ones come on
got them you start to realize the danger
when you're
chipping away the waves coming in you
let go did you let go of the the goods
did you save onto your life
100 euros a kilo one of the most
expensive shellfish anywhere on the
planet
i see why now because of the most
dangerous let's go amazing
this confirms how rugged but stunning
this country is
especially on the coastline because look
at it to the naked eye just looks like
you know waves pounding the rocks but
there's so much activity under there
and it's incredible good job though
honestly
amazing adventurous dangerous stupid and
delicious
[Music]
you